today's topic flight reacts flat reacts
as a youtuber very large youtuber who
plays a lot of nba 2k and he's popular
on twitch as well
we actually already covered one of his
videos where he had to break up with
another girl and was hella
toxic was the word i would use because
it was you guys go check that video
recently he
got into another uh issue which was live
streamed uh with another woman and
we're gonna play that so just to be
clear um flighta tweeted out that he was
broken up with her
that he didn't want to be with her
anymore after she's been repeatedly
doing certain things
and so while he was live streaming to a
whole audience
she just insisted on coming to his place
and this is what happened
you're crazy
you've got nothing to say all right
let's keep playing
you're wasting your time i'm not i'm not
going to force you out i'm not going to
touch you or nothing
i don't know why what are you you're
wasting your time right now like
just no i'm not into nothing all right
just get your [ __ ] stop don't touch
don't touch no you're talking
i'm not talking to you yes no just get
off get off the stream
sorry daddy delete the tweet you don't
know how to act
oh actually for your daddy to read it no
yes
deleted daddy daddy daddy delete the
tweet
we're not separated daddy delete the
tweet come on second [ __ ] you
daddy
[Music]
yes daddy does that doja that's dojo
right
whatever those are sucks i got so much
to say but i'm gonna save it for later
because
this
no daddy
worry on the world hey man listen i
always get super offended
whenever women do this like cutesy voice
and think they're going to change my
mind
i don't know how you guys are but me
personally when a girl goes come on
please
when they do that it makes me want to
double down and say no to you even
further just to teach you to be a
[ __ ] grown up
you know the slight chance now you
killed it you killed it like if i say no
to you and you go
come on baby please i'm like no
i'll go like double down just to
reinforce to you that you need to talk
to me like a grown person
if i assert my boundaries you trying to
make yourself look more cute or to use
your
femininity to get try to get your way i
will purposefully try to tear that [ __ ]
down and the fact that she does this
this often and she's doing this this
much means
to me that he's allowed her to get her
way when she's done this
because i'll be honest with you people
only do as much as you allow them that's
why a lot of you are never going to end
up in a situation like this
because you would never allow it to get
to that point but if it's gone to this
point
you've already said yes too many times
you've already violated your own
boundaries too many times for
this to be this comfortable on a live
stream [ __ ]
trust me if you say yes too many times
and you go back on your decision
there's no good that comes out of there
when we're doing today's video i don't
want to do this to
flight i don't want to do it as a girl
this is for you guys who are watching at
home to understand how to avoid these
kind of situations and these kind of
people
because it's not just because flight
makes money that he gets to you can get
it when you're broken poor
all right there's nothing to do with
that so you guys need to learn
what to avoid and what to not allow
because i can assure you
either you allow this monster to get to
where it's at now by feeding it
or you constantly have a habit of
attracting people and allowing people
into your life
who engage in this kind of behavior
either way you want to be able to
see that habit that you have and nip it
in the butt so it doesn't keep [ __ ]
with you
over over okay don't start don't start
with [ __ ] you get mad at me about
because you're not gonna go there
that's her real face right like you saw
the whole cute stuff afterwards
now that she's getting mad she can't
hide anymore right because she puts out
an air
to the world to try to look respectable
but the moment he said too much
she couldn't control herself that's her
real face and also notice how she's
using physical touch
as a means to assert herself coerce
that's the word let's be honest this
whole video what you guys are gonna see
is this is how women get very physical
and they coerce you
and this is also how men allow it and
also encourage it
right there all this touching after you
told her i don't want you in my house
take your
stuff and go notice how she's violated
boundaries and started touching him
to not only one cross out boundary but
to to
try to seduce him women do this often
hair fro just get it
just get your stuff bro no i'm not going
to force you i'm not going
respectfully just for real no
you want to show them this side of a
relationship we're going to show them we
do this all the time like all the time
like if i had i told you if i have to
ever tweet out something that i'm single
that means it's no looking back because
you push me there
so it's like there's something so cringy
about seeing her trying to rub his back
and smiling for the camera while he's
there like yo i don't want you here
there's such a disconnect
in between how they're presenting and
the reality the situation it's you know
what i'm talking about
it's like that fake smile that people
have when this whole thing could have
been avoided if you didn't
tweeting your relationship status
no you talk about it you talk it i know
in that situation you can't really talk
to the person
but tweeting it ain't gonna ain't gonna
do it like it's
i don't know it's probably me i don't
expose my like that
i don't expose certain aspects of my
life but tweeting it just now he's just
live
i would have paused it i would have
dealt with it broadcasting that out
there
there's my cringe starts from there
broadcasting and keep on broadcasting
the thing out there and keep
if he could do it and he feels
comfortable with it that's fine but i
i'm talking about me
not him i'm talking about me i wouldn't
do that i reject the notion that
this could have been avoided if you
didn't tweet fair you know what i'm yeah
yeah yeah i'm not even gonna say that
yeah you're right you're right okay
you're right
i don't even think that it would have
been avoided if it would it wouldn't
tweet but it's just
this is what i'm saying broadcasting all
of that
yeah out there super messy broadcast the
tweet is messy
staying there on the live while she's
there is messy cut that
i'll be back guys you know what take a
big brief ball
pause and i'll be back i agree with
everything you said
except for the tweet part but you do
that but as far as the live streaming it
i'm not even mad at him
because being alone with a woman without
cameras on when she's unstable
you gonna take that risk or would you
rather have a hundred thousand witness
know that you didn't do anything wrong
you got a point there
right i've been in situations behind
closed door where i activated my camera
i said she's acting
funny she might do some things i need
some proof because then he said she said
they're gonna believe you she [ __ ] she
sure they're gonna believe her no no i
yeah i speak from having been there this
time i'm like whoa
got a point you have to have
yo you know what i'ma give flight
another l for being with a woman who
giggles and laughs like that
wow you know what i just imagined my
head like nails on a chalkboard what was
that
what was that bro i'm gonna give you
like five ten minutes for
i'm gonna mute it don't don't turn my
[ __ ] off i will no you're not you don't
end i will i'm not into the [ __ ] i'm
muted
that's it we can talk this is why you
don't negotiate with a terrorist you try
to give a little bit should i take more
some of y'all need to learn how to say
no to stick with it he said no get out
right now
she kept insisting and he's like fine
i'll give you five ten minutes then she
try to take more this is what i mean
when i say when you have your boundaries
asserted and don't just compromise
everything because she keeps insisting
if people are coercing you into
something you didn't want to do
yeah no you're not you don't and i will
i'm not in the stream i'm muted
that's she's trying to bang afterwards
that's what she just said
again another tactic we don't talk about
this often but sometimes they use that
to get what they want
give up the pom pom they do andrea you
crazy
um she was doing [ __ ] as soon as the
stream ended
bro non-stop screaming bro like just
topping lunch screaming streaming
streaming um she had water bottles on
her bro
you know what i'm saying i literally was
catching and blocking them shit's like
delete come out
delete it delete what you're stupid
[ __ ] play [ __ ]
but i don't want to be with you no more
what happened to that cute voice
what happened is what happens when the
cameras are off or when they think the
camera's off
at this point you cause the cops get an
ro on this girl
yeah but i ain't no snitch no you a fool
you a fool
because she gonna get your ass in jail
if you if you want to play yourself i
ain't gonna call cops cause your girl
gonna send you in jail go ahead
keep playing stupid bro what the [ __ ]
bro stop hitting my [ __ ]
bro stop hitting my
you're trespassing and you're damaging
my property at this point
because i don't want you here guys stop
covering for these women all right
stop covering for these people who break
your stuff and do all this stop you're
not helping them
you're enabling them they're gonna do
this to the next person if i go to my
girlfriend
and she doesn't want me at her house and
i lock myself
up and i break her [ __ ] it's a wrap
it's done so i don't even see and
understand why i couldn't be the same
basically
we know 20 minutes later [ __ ] cops
come
what's up is there a reason why you're
screaming
you're going to break [ __ ] no she
girlfriend
yeah okay can we talk out here uh he
talks to her
why are they separating them is because
they don't want the other one to
influence the other one yeah so they
separate them so they can get
misinformation procedures
thank you honestly both of them all
it was like three cops at my door bro
none of them were really hostile they
were trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
was going on
did you guys break anything did you guys
put your hands on each other what
happened
and i gave her the same [ __ ] answer
five to six times i said
i d k i don't know ends up saying um oh
do you need her like removed from the
crib or whatever and i was just like
no like nothing happened i don't even
know what you're talking about you know
what i'm saying
see this is what i'm talking about this
is how men play themselves if things
goes worse than that
and he goes back on what he just said
it's done we're not gonna believe you
because now what we can't we can't
believe you
you're going back on what you said so
you lied the first time
you don't do not go back on what you're
saying so that's the love that i have
for her i ended up doing that
and uh she did the same thing damn near
to um and they just ended up both
leaving
as soon as they ended up leaving she
gets the screaming again
she gets the the the banyan throwing
[ __ ] mind you know what i'm saying when
she's banging throwing
she's throwing little [ __ ] like this
chair you know saying trash can my bag
around
and then it just got to a point i'm just
like bro because like they basically
broke it down to me like
i apparently had a noise complaint from
the past before
that was already on the record um on
this on the place i'm at
and they basically said if i get another
one where they have a cops come to the
door i'ma get evicted
you know what i'm saying so i had to
play my cards right
so bro like honestly was just like i'ma
just post this [ __ ]
because what i was doing i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't see what anybody got to say
some people are going to be like flight
like why didn't you like you know what
i'm saying like
step your game up why don't you slap the
girl
why don't you why don't you beat that
ass
that's why you're sitting on the
bleachers and unsuccessful in life bro
i know how to finesse the situation how
are you going to try to act like you
know how to finesse the situation but
you keep ending up in the same situation
with these broads that's true
at which point is it your fault for
allowing these types of women to come to
your life
at which point is it your fault for
allowing these things to escalate to the
point
i can't tell people to fix their
toxicity they need therapy they all
that's fine
what i can say is though like yo guys or
women there's people out there who are
trying to do you harm you need to make
sure that you don't allow them into your
life that's the only thing we could do
in flat you have to accept some kind of
accountability for the fact that you
keep ending up in these plots because
it's not
me it's not preach it's not the people
watching you either
that's what i'm confused about when i
watch is it's like are you not aware
do you think this is a boss thing if i
end up in a situation like this my
thought process is not like damn i
handle this like a box you know what i
thought is
how did i let this trash ass person into
my life
how did i not see this happen how did i
not see this coming
how did i not see that the fact that
this toxic person was approaching me and
i couldn't tell too many people were
like man they hurt me this is that not
that it's necessarily your fault but how
did we get there
exactly how did we end up we being the
operative word
people oh this is victim blame you call
it whatever you want where i'm from it's
called self-preservation
if you want to survive and this is not
even like a relationship this is a life
thing you need to assess
why and what you can do if you live in a
shitty ass spot and you got the
disposable income to leave
because you keep getting robbed all the
time and all this [ __ ] well take that
disposable income and get the [ __ ] out
you wouldn't be like oh my god all these
criminals you can't afford to think
like that when you live in a shitty ass
place the circumstances are what they
are
what can you do as a smart person
to get out of these be like well this is
a woman you would never i say this all
the time
whether it's a man whether it's a woman
i don't care i do not care
what can you guys do to protect
yourselves that's all that matters
so when i watch this i'm just like
flight man you've been this is goofy
it's the same
as the last time what do you think you
can call all the people toxic toxic
toxic you have to see where
have we gone wrong what happened and if
it keeps happening you have to figure
out what it is about you about your
patterns
that keeps happening there's a pattern
there's something there
there's something that keeps repeating
itself you have to be able to decode
that accountability
yes trash okay what makes it that you
engage with trash people
yeah and and you know more than that
also i think a lot of people don't
recognize how common this kind of
behavior is
maybe not to this degree of intensity
what is the grievance but i mean even in
lesser degrees it's very common you know
some people i would never but you still
do little things
right you might still go through the
phone you might still hit your man every
now and then you might try to still
coarse him into things he didn't want to
do and look we're all learning and
growing i can't say that in my past i've
been 100
i'm the first to admit i've made some
fuck-ups too but i've also been on the
receiving end of these fuck-ups from
people who were unaware of what they
were doing and
there's a lot of learning that has to
happen both as men but also as women
right the fact that she's like this is
because nobody has ever told her
to act right she's always gotten her way
and so if you always expect men to be
the ones to tell you like yo get in your
space ladies you also have to do some
self-reflecting if you want some decent
relationships
that's what it comes down to it's good
that you you're able to know
that and you're able to say and you're
able to admit that you've been the first
we all have
we all have some whether it's with
girlfriends whether it's with friends or
the relationship that we have
hold ourselves accountable for what we
did and then grow from that
because we can do better we all have we
all have you know a relationship with
friends
even with friends yep especially over
the last 15 years life has changed so
much
so many new concepts have come to life
so much knowledge is constantly thrown
at us
we're not having to undo a lot of like
societal norms that we've always
accepted
right it's tough to be here and be like
change because yo it's tough to
assimilate or listen to change your
behavior takes time so i don't say this
you know to be like you guys can't fix
you guys can't prove you certainly can
and if you have this habit
bonus is on you to try to improve but
when i watch this video from flight what
has struck
me is like he doesn't seem to realize in
which ways he
is causing these loops to happen sure
maybe now he's actually cut it off when
you need to cut off and that's great
apparently he's done with it
congratulations
but also ask yourself how did you get to
that point
how did you get there you need to figure
that out what are you doing that you're
always falling for these kind of women
i'll be honest with you i took a look
one look at her instagram i was like
yeah that's what i expect you found her
i mean no she's a public person i even
got to watch her response video
zero self-awareness zero flight you got
with a
crazy person and they acted crazy you
got with loco and they ended up loco
and for that you need to hold that l
anyways tell us what you guys think in
the comments below
and if you guys liked today's video hit
that like button subscribe all right a
lot of you already watching up just
sub all right there's a lot of great
[Music]
content
foreign